oh goopity goop goop goop
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome back
to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by
squarespace and we're going to be taking
a look
at one of the most famous and also one
of the more controversial
wellness blogs on the internet gweneth
paltrow's
goop but before we do a quick note about
my sponsor squarespace who
you know i talk about often because i'm
just a huge fan
of what they do now if you're not
familiar with squarespace it's an
all-in-one platform to run your business
whether you're looking to build a
website
blog online store or use their marketing
tools and analytics
i am admittedly not very tech savvy so
i often find it really overwhelming to
coordinate all the moving parts
on my blog using a service like
squarespace to easily miniature seo
email list and calendar not to mention
easily
import information from twitter and
instagram can be a huge
time saver and of course be very
convenient it's also nice
not to stress over the little things and
instead to focus on what really matters
so you can check out squarespace.com for
a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
abby sharp to save 10 off of your first
purchase of a website or domain
now i also want to draw attention to the
disclaimer on the screen
and in the description that includes a
trigger warning for sensitive die
culture discussions
and of course don't forget to subscribe
and ring that little bell so that you
never miss out on a video
alright folks let's talk about goop
now unless you've somehow managed to
escape all things croc shittery in this
world
you are probably all well aware that
goop
is a hotbed for shady health information
or misinformation i should probably say
in fact goop and its front woman gwyneth
have kind of made it an apparent
favorite pastime to perpetuate
inaccurate and pseudoscience-like claims
i mean does anybody else remember the
jade egg gate
of 2017 anyway i could probably pull up
almost any page of the website and have
something critical to
say about it but as we stroll into
new year new you season i thought we
would focus
on the kind of crap that we see on a lot
of these websites this time of year
diets and detoxes if you are
a frequent viewer of almost any abby's
kitchen video
you probably already know how i feel
about the double d's kill me
right now diets and by that i'm actually
talking
specifically about overly restrictive
fad diets
you know they just don't work and
detoxes
no oh hell no not only is it
scientifically
untrue that you are able to initiate a
magical detox in your body
as your liver kidneys immune system
lungs
skin and lymphatic systems are
constantly doing
a pretty fine job on this on their own
but i would argue that in the wake of
wellness culture
the sexy d word detox has effectively
replaced
the bad d word diet the difference
well diets tend to be viewed through a
lens of
weight loss while detoxes are almost
always in the name of better health or
wellness but honestly this is just the
same pig with a new coat of lipstick
as disappointing and repetitive as this
may be
it is important to me to continue to
debunk this type of content
until it no longer exists on the
internet
[Music]
now with all that being said i
introduced you
three bogus detoxes and diets that you
do not
need to participate in the new year
courtesy of course
of goob now we're gonna kick off this
video with goop's annual
five-day new year's detox the 2020
edition
now according to the website this
five-day cleanse
is inspired by dr alejandro younger's
basic elimination diet
outlined in goops program clean
there are a lot of words in that
sentence that i don't feel good about
now i am all for taking on an
elimination diet under the right
circumstances however not only are they
often completely unnecessary
but they're also not advisable to
complete on your own
if they've not been prescribed by a
healthcare professional
do not fit your unique medical needs and
furthermore
are not carried out under the proper
medical supervision
moving on this blog post also says that
january is a
good time to help our bodies catch up
with detoxification
and give our detox organs a chance to
rest
and recover rest and recover from
what like what else would they be doing
if they're not working and and do i
really want one of my vital organs to go
on vacation
no thank you folks your body's organs
are a complex
and highly efficient system that do the
job of
detoxing your body all on their own
of course getting regular exercise and
adequate nutrition
aid in your body's natural detoxing
activities like
sweating and moving your bowels but
there's no specific diet
or meal plan that will automatically
detox your body further to this
our detox organs are quite literally
always doing their job and are also
unaware of our man-made calendar year
they don't know
that it's the new year and that it's
their time for their annual holiday
anyways let's move on to the actual food
plan
uh so in an effort to be concise i'm not
gonna break down every single day but
i will give you a general feel for let's
call it what it is
this diet now first you are supposed to
eliminate
caffeine alcohol dairy gluten corn
nightshade vegetables
refined sugar shellfish white rice eggs
and soy
that sucks there's also a lot of trendy
suggestions
including starting every morning with
warm lemon water
and sipping bone broth throughout the
day
i just can't
i feel like i have said this a million
times before but
lemon water doesn't detox you and bone
broth
while nutritious and protein rich will
not
heal your gut let's move that
along so what the heck do you get to eat
well your meals generally are composed
of things like
green smoothies vegetable soups and
trail mixes
obviously so very restrictive expensive
and ridiculously low in calories i mean
what else would a goop detox be
well there is a disclaimer on the blog
post that you should eat more if you're
hungry after one of the prescribed meals
and this is true
obviously it also kind of makes me sad
that
a sentiment as intuitive as this one
isn't implicit and it has to be actually
stated there ugh
okay well to wrap up this first detox i
want to just say that the blog post
also states that the food editor at goop
collaborates with people who have
a bachelor of science or phd in
nutrition
and while it is obviously a really good
thing that health professionals were
consulted
to some degree in the formulation of
this diet i'm also just a bit
disappointed
that a health professional would condone
the suggestion to
do a complete elimination diet without
any one-on-one support
this is something that is highly
individualized
and something you absolutely should seek
out
the advice of a medical professional
before you start
okay we are only one-third of the way
through and i'm already hungry
and sadly our next post is probably not
going to
give us much more to chew on i introduce
to you
how to lose weight fast with celebrity
fitness entrepreneur
tracy anderson now quite honestly
if i were to look up toxic dye culture
in the dictionary
this blog post might appear as the first
result there is
so much problematic language used
throughout this article
but i'm going to share the highlight
reel if you want to call it that
so first anderson gives the most general
and stereotypical advice for everyone
to get off gluten and go very low carb
now in case you're still subject to the
gluten fear-mongering of the
2010s the only reason to get off gluten
is if you have a gluten sensitivity or
celiac disease
also carbs are not to be feared even if
weight loss is your goal
now while anderson is correct in saying
that this technique can make you
lose weight fast a lot of the immediate
weight loss that occurs when following a
low carb diet
is from a depletion in water weight and
glycogen stores
not from fat so while most research
suggests that short-term weight loss
tends to be greater on a low-carb diet
compared to a low-fat one one
meta-analysis found that
in the long term they pretty much even
themselves out
finding a way of eating that you can
stick to is a
much bigger determinant in one's success
at losing weight
and keeping that weight off in the long
term so
bottom line low carb does not work for
everyone
hard stop let's move on now if we
continue along with this misinformed
diet advice
we see that the sales funnel opens up
with an easy route to purchase
tracy anderson's own protein bar
yes love it when i'm convinced that i
need to change
my body in all these crazy restrictive
challenging ways
only to be sold a quick fix to solve all
of my problems
but wait it actually gets worse it gets
way [ __ ] worse she then goes on to
suggest that you can lose 14 pounds in
four
weeks which is twice as fast as most
legit nutrition professionals
would ever recommend for safe
sustainable
weight loss i also just need to say that
while i'm not mad that she says you can
have one to two glasses of wine per day
i also can't condone this recommendation
in conjunction with severe dietary
restriction
yes of course wine is totally fine in
moderation
but when your calories are so restricted
every little bite of nutrition counts
and i would rather as a dietitian
that a person get 150 calories from real
whole foods that are rich
in fiber-rich carbs and and protein and
fats
then wine and speaking of restricted
calories
the woman then talks about how you can
lose weight within a 48-hour
window suggesting that you just stick
with the
leanest options in her plan her
recommendations are to have
tea with protein powder at breakfast
a poached egg and a small salad with
rice wine vinegar
for lunch half of an altar ego dark
chocolate bar for a snack
and then some steamed or grilled plain
fish with steamed spinach or asparagus
for dinner
that is like 800 calories that is not
enough food for
my toddler never mind a grown-ass adult
who she also suggests
should do a sweaty muscular structure
and cardio workout
uh do you want people to faint
according to her you can also lose up to
four
but likely two pounds in two days
that is insane like two to four pounds
of water weight
maybe two to four pounds in fat
no let's just be clear to lose
four pounds of fat you would need to put
yourself in a caloric deficit
of 14 000 calories so unless you're
used to eating 8 000 calories a day and
then subsisting
on this diet plan you're not gonna get
there honey
and i guess you're gonna know it because
tracy suggests that you get on the scale
every single day please friends do not
do that
the scale is just one of many tools to
help you
in your weight loss goals but weighing
yourself
every day tells you nothing literally
tells you nothing of value our weight
shifts every day due to what we eat
bowel movements hormones fluid intake
and so
much more it does not tell you how your
diet is going
or how your health is improving after a
few days
of eating steamed fish and veg and it
definitely
does not tell us anything about our
worth
holy i'm getting riled up here alright
let's close up today's list with another
classic
detox fad the heavy metal detox guide
this one was created in collaboration
with the infamous
medical medium you know the celery juice
guy who
despite his alias is a psychic not a
doctor
just to be clear now since i've already
talked about this snake oil salesman and
his croc of crap claims about bile salts
and
magic celery juice ad nauseam on the
channel
today i will be just looking at this
specific
protocol on goop now before we even get
into the diet itself
let's talk about what heavy metals are
and why this medium wants us to
get rid of them so badly so heavy metals
things like arsenic cadmium lead and
mercury
are able to enter the body through
environmental exposure
such as through the skin by inhalation
or by ingestion
while heavy metal toxicity is rare it
can be
pretty dangerous resulting in everything
from digestive distress
to fever to coma and death so goop got
it right that
yeah we don't want a buildup of heavy
metals
going on in our bodies but they kind of
left
out the itty-bitty detail that
that does not actually happen that much
in fact it really would only occur if
you were exposed to a
heavy metal in exorbitant amounts over a
really long period of time
something that would likely not occur
under
normal living conditions i don't know
most of us are not hot boxing ourselves
in a room with
wet lead-based paint for weeks at a time
but anyways let's dive into their diet
advice
so according to this article foods to
eat in order to
rid your body of heavy metals include
spirulina
barley grass juice extract powder
cilantro
atlantic dulse and wild blueberries but
only the ones from maine because
apparently
only those will do that's gonna make for
like
one really interesting meal
but culinary chops aside let's talk
about the actual research
we do have actual research to support
chelation
or using certain agents to bind and then
pull out heavy metals from the body
though this is largely in relation to
pharmaceuticals
not fancy foods interestingly dietary
fiber
is thought to be an accessory in
chelation therapy
except not soluble fiber which can
actually increase the absorption
of heavy metals so it's possible that
this is the rationale for the
blueberries on their list
since blueberries are rich in insoluble
fiber
i don't know like kind of grasping at
straws here
but anyway cilantro and cholera which
is accustomed to the spirulina on the
list have been shown to help with
heavy metal chelation over time but
much of this research has been done in
animal studies
and the only one that i could find that
was done on humans
actually found that cilantro extract was
no more effective than a placebo
in increasing heavy metal excretion so
cilantro haters rejoice you don't have
to eat that for the sake of a toxin-free
life now beyond specific food
suggestions the other tips in this
article for removing
heavy metals from the body include
reducing dietary fat
drinking lemon water of course having
aloe vera leaf juice infrared saunas
and juice fasting honestly how many
times do we need to go through this
folks
this all sounds like total pseudoscience
to me
most of these suggestions are likely to
induce sweating
peeing and pooping all of which are your
body's
natural ways of detoxing as for the
low-fat thing
i guess it's because a lot of heavy
metals are stored in fat
so i guess eating less fatty animals
would reduce your intake
sure i mean we do know that fatty bottom
feeder fish like tuna
can have higher amounts of mercury in
them
but that doesn't mean that we need to
swear off all fat
like why not try to up your plant-based
fats like nuts
olives avocados and seeds
this is just so bad at the end of the
day
i'm sure you are all able to see that
the research on this topic
remains relatively new pretty
controversial
and most certainly not definitive
especially considering that the majority
of studies done on this
have been conducted on animals and not
humans
although there are shreds of evidence to
support these foods for a
heavy metal detox their value isn't much
more than just in supporting your body
in doing what it naturally does to detox
that is
peeing pooping sweating etc
not to mention if you're actually
dealing with legit
heavy metal poisoning you need medical
attention
not a diet from a psychic on a lifestyle
website i also want to point out that
there is actually disclaimer
at the bottom of the article which says
and i quote
editor's note we trust that you'll
quickly understand that this medical
medium
is operating well outside the bounds of
medicine
and science but to avoid any confusion
our in-house phds want to remind readers
that his claims cannot be substantiated
by science
so yeah ironically enough
my thoughts are summed up pretty nicely
by their own disclaimer
yeah anyways i guess i'll just finish by
reminding you to
please remain cautious of any health and
wellness information that you get online
while it can be fun to get new recipes
or tips from a variety of sources
including goop i think it's best that we
leave topics such as disease
and weight loss to the registered
healthcare professionals
and on that note a big thank you to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
also if you guys have any particular
articles products or protocols from
goop or any other website or brand that
you want me to review
definitely send them my way and if you
like this video give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on what you
want me to review next subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye